Thanks, Susan. Now here's an interesting finding. Using neural imaging,
researchers found that when Genie was listening or speaking, the activity in
her brain was located mostly in the right hemisphere. Now remember, we just
mentioned that language comprehension and production is located in the left
hemisphere. This led researchers to suggest that the left hemisphere speech
development requires stimulation from the environment. During what's called
sensitivity period if it's to develop properly. The sensitivity period are ages
before critical stimulation and learning must occur, otherwise the window of
learning will close and it will become very difficult to learn languages. If
you are interested learning more about this case study, the movie Mockingbird
Don't Sing, is based on her life story. Although tragic, it demonstrates again
how much we can learn from human thought and behavior by using case studies
such as these.